jobs done warcraft consider this to be
an overdue review and I was not going to
talk about this movie I really wasn't
but you know what i am susceptible to
peer pressure and when a couple of
people were like no we want you to do a
video I'm like fine I'll do a video did
this is your fault Jeff a case first
little bit of background for my stance
on warcraft as a video game franchise
which i think we're still going to
consider it i don't think we're going to
go and now film franchise there but in
any case my thing with warcraft i played
warcraft to beating warcraft 3 beat it I
never play World of Warcraft that's
mainly because I new home how much time
i had lost to diablo 2 I was pretty sure
that world of warcraft would have
swallowed my life so I never did world
of warcraft and my sort of knowledge of
the lore at this point primarily comes
from playing hearthstone every now and
again so i have a working knowledge of
some of the major features a lot of the
general background details of this world
end of this story i think more so than
you expect from most mainstream
audiences so in a way i should have a
leg up going into this right no not so
much seriously i came back close to
opening up a wiki while I was watching
this thing I said no that's cheating
I'll try and accept this thing on his
own terms but you you can't I mean
unless you are just dredged in Warcraft
lore you will not be able to keep track
of what is going on there just dropping
names of locations of characters and
they they keep referring to these these
are main characters on put that in
quotes on explain why in a minute they
keep dropping their names over and over
and over again but we never really get
to know any of these characters so that
on top of the fact that so many names
get thrown out at us base
anytime a character's name was said in
that character was not right there in
the shot I was always going wait who is
that and what I put quotes around main
characters that has to do with the fact
that this thing doesn't give us any
development of really anybody we're
shown these characters and we're told
all this stuff about them but this this
movie for the budget that it has and how
much money you can see that they spent
it does a lot of telling over showing I
mean ridiculously so the number of major
plot points that happened off screen and
just get talked about I like the very
first time that the orcs attack a human
civilization that should be a hew-mon
huge moment that is the end that sparks
war this is called war crafton we don't
see it at all Amy between show the orcs
coming to this world and then there's a
couple of scenes couple of cups and then
it's bunch of human nights and a king
talking about how their villages are
being attacked and I'm going well huh
that was one point especially early on I
swear to God that I wish I'd actually
time this because it it felt like the
thing jump location 4 times in 4 minutes
and introduced six new characters I'm
CGI's it's fine it's not great it
doesn't look real ok so if you go in
expecting realistic CGI it's not this is
not the dawn of the Planet of the Apes
it's not even close but I will say I got
used to it over time it's not bad it
looks interesting it's not dull to look
at it's just not real you know I said we
didn't get to know any of the main
characters very well and most of them we
go for how in the first of all too many
dang characters and we don't get to know
most of them very well at all outside
from their plot function so we've got
these things that are supposed to be big
emotional moments like a character who
loses a son and like these old friends
and there's betrayals they go on but we
haven't seen it we haven't seen these
relationships we haven't spent time with
his father is on so that
any impact we haven't spent I'm seeing
these people be friends before things
started afraid we just see come apart
we're taking the movies word on context
rather than having any of it some of the
orcs fair but actually as a whole the
orc story works much better than the
human story and fortunately the orcs
don't get as much time but the orc
characters are slightly more developed
than the human characters moments that
we get with up actually build the
relationships and things just a little
bit more not quite enough where I'm
gotta go this is what the movie should
have done because it wasn't really doing
that well either but it was doing that
better with the orcs that it was with
humans now here's the really infuriating
thing for as much as I've just been
complaining and pretty much non-stop
about this thing there are moments when
it is so much fun the first action scene
like the real first real serious fight
between the orcs and humans I had make
sure you grab my face I'm watching or
can lift up a horse and throw it at
night it was awesome that it was fun and
it was such a small percentage of this
two-hour movie I kind of wish good this
thing got so bogged down and trying to
convey all the lore that ain't forgot to
be entertaining because what actually
gives us some of these combat moments
and some of these fights and we get
basically what it lightens up on the
epicness of it and just is it's fun
there are even some cool little nods to
the game that I thought were fun I heard
a murmur gurgle that may be gritty
hugely and that was the kind of Easter
eggs they needed to be dropping as
opposed to just tossing fifty thousand
names that if you aren't memorizing the
wiki page on warcraft mean nothing to
you and ultimately that's where the
frustration comes in is that there were
glimpses and moments of how fun this
could be I think the thing took itself
too seriously I think you needed to
lighten up and be a little bit more
camping a little bit more embracing of
the absurdity of this cuz this is nuts
now it's not as self serious as say
batman v superman and as a result I
would actually say this is more
entertaining than batman be superman i'm
not going to go so far as to say it's
actually a better movie it probably
isn't but it's more fun and I would
watch this again before I would watch
batman be superman again i'll tell you
that if you are ever going to watch this
if you haven't already here's a drinking
game for you take a drink every single
time somebody says where's the Guardian
what's going on with the Guardian
somebody get the guardian or any very
dumb something like that you will be
blitzed throughout this whole movie so
there you go with Warcraft did you sit
through this thing going by the box
office you probably didn't but if you
did what were your thoughts on it drop
something down on the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks where i actually did a
live streaming reaction to this movie so
you can check out that if you want to
give a listen to the counsel of the
geeks podcasts on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned